CRALHE ILLEDT, RE
FA C TCEALN  MASTER TRUMTOLD THE
N DOES.
AS FOR HOW HIS FATHER HAS BEEN ,
HEING, HOENIG.FIRST TO.
SIGNALBIG SENT OFF
DEAL, THE INDICTMES JU HUNT.
E SCENES?O SEEER'S
WHAT IS THE REALEELING AMONG ID
PRHIS AS A
WITCH HUNT A D ATIRT OF THAT IGH
VANCE.
OF THAT IS GOING TO BE USE OF R
IS ON THISWITH NCE.EALITYOND SO
ADVISERS THIS WEEK ABOUT HOWE
WANQLLED.
HAPPY NOT SOMETHING HE'S TA
ABOUT CONSTANTLY B
THIS IS NOT WHERE  Y NED FOR
SE PRESIDENT HAT WHAT YOU'VE
EMF  HIS ALLIES IS
THEYNFLATED LEGAL
PROBLEMSITIC RNGE ARE LOSING SIS
NOT AN INDICTMENT.
ITNT OF DONALD
TRUMP PERSONALLY BUT IT IS OF
HIS D COMPANIES.
OUGHT AGAINST SOMEBODY
ELSE.
IS FACINPOL JAIL  CAN CHANG
HE HASNDICATED HE'S NO
TO COOPERA
BUT WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS WAS THO
PRESIDENT'S REGULAR TV
>> THE FORMER ENT WAS TELY WATC
ABOUT HOW HEES TELEVISION  GLUE
ENT
BACKOU LKSD
TNGE TV IS OFTE ALLWA
YESTY.>> FROM A LEGA N
T HAS COMEND
GONE.
PROSECUTORS, STILL TT
WEISSELBERG TO FLIP?
>> I THINK S
THERE'S ONE OF TWONGS THAT
STCTMENT
SCENARLD
PROSECUTORS SHOOTING THEIR SHOT,
G THEIR BEST FOOT FORWARD
AND HOPING THEY T
OUT OF TS.
CASE REALL
NOT MUCH.I THINK WHAT SCENARIO
IG TOUTOR FOR A
STRATEGICALLY RG
AND PRESSURE ALLEN WEISSELBERG
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO BREAK INTO
ED ORGANIZAT THE
TRUMON
PROSECUTORS OK AT THE CHARY
WHO MIGHT BE VULNERABLE, WHOFLIO
TH
OUAT THAT, NE IN THE RCLE H
THST NAME TRUMP.
T GOING TOLIP.K THE PROSECUTS
TH.N PEOPLE I NEVER
THING TO CASE NG FORWARD.WMENT
>> ELIE, I LRNY TAUGHT A CLASS
IPU AT G
SC?Y YIO G AND HITEAMW
HELEARNT YESTERDAY.
WHEN I LOOKED AT THAT
INDICTMENT, I WILL TELL YOE  AG
WASIGNIFICANTLN I SUSPECTED.JOH
EVIDENCE. A
ANOTHER PIECE OFVIJUMPED OFF TH
THEY HEV
LBERG TAMPERED WIT
RE, THAT HE TOLD ANOTHER
ON AT THE TRUMP WORLD TA M THE
CUSE MY AT IS RELYTIIF HE'S SITT
HAVE TO TELL HIM, THEY G CASE AU
O TURN 7ARS D,.
AND IF YOU GET CON HERE, YOU CO
YEARS.
TO LET THAT SIT FOR
AT  PROSECUTOR. I THINK PEOPLE
A FAMILY BUSINESS, AIVELL IN SO"
INESS ALMOST
WHAT WILL THE EFFECT BE?
>> SO, JOHN, BIGGEST
IGHT NOWS
MEANS IN TERMSE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION'S RELNSS IN VARIOU
WHETHER ATNDER
SPECIFIC PROPERTIES, LRSWE'RT AW
BUT OFERE ARE
COVENANTS THAT ARE AGREED TOBET
PROJECT  AAMOUNT
CAPITAL THAT IS BEING GIVEN
E SOME OF THOSE T
THERE CAN BE SITUATIONS CREATEHS
LENDERS HE
ABIL BAN
WOUL THE ABILITY TO
.
NOONRY
CHME IN TERMS OFS.
UG FROM HIM, EVEN WHEN BANKS
WAY.
SO WE WILL SEE.
BUT THAT WT .
>> IF YOU'RE ALLEN WEISSELRG
LAERIM
AGINABT ST THINGLIVE GOT A
COOPERATING.
ANY PERSON WHO'SONS.
NUMBER ONEU ERATE.
IF YOUO VETHE NA
OF THE CHARGES HERA D CHANCEO G.
TIWOS YOD
HOUT COOPERATING,
OU, MR. WEISSELBEREM
THRE GUIDELINES TWO, OR
BUI OR YOU
WE WOULD BE ROLLING E DICETION E
TRIAL.
AN W ADVISES A TRIAL HAS
DEFENDANTS GET CONVICTED AT
TRIA
IF YOU GET CVI
U WILL LIKY GET
SES IN PRISON.
E E THREE OPTIONS HE'S
SITTING WITH.
ONE OF TTHAT'S
SAID, THE A
EN
PEOPLE COOPE THE ME URSE, TOINI
REDU J
RUNS  THE
MONEY TO PAY THE LAWYERS, THE
E, VBECAUSE WE HAVE TO RUNS OUTA
WHAT IE FO FOCUSED ONT THIS POI?
CS OR BUSINESS?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU SETE
THEM, JOHN.
INK THE POLITIIV HIM
SOME OF A  TO SAY
ISPOLITICAWI
I THINK HEYWD THTI HIM TO
NGSAYS HE  RT AGAIN  IT O RAISYA
CASE.ICSN .'S NOT THE CASTH THI
FOR OPTI HAS BEEQUESTITHAT HOGGO